Xbox has had quite the year and with
Game Pass many gamers were able to
experience games they otherwise wouldn't
have like tunic immortality pentiment
and a plague tale Requiem Xbox wrapped
up this year with Heavy Hitters like the
Callisto protocol and Marvel's midnight
Suns but 2023 is a new year so here are
some of the best games you have to look
forward to in 2023 and Beyond
originally set to release in 2022
Bethesda game Studio's first new IP in
over 25 years Starfield has been pushed
to 2023. Starfield takes the classic
Elder Scrolls and Fallout formula into
space with a seemingly dizzying amount
of content from the official gameplay
reveal Todd Howard announced there would
be over 100 star systems players could
experience with over 1 000 planets all
explorable whether this will be
procedurally generated Allah no man's
sky or handcrafted isn't yet known
regardless of your thoughts on the scope
if you're a fan of Skyrim or Fallout
this is likely going to be a game worth
visiting and hopefully a return to form
for Bethesda after Fallout 76 Starfield
is currently set to release sometime
within the first half of 2023
[Music]
while we're on the subject of Bethesda
Bethesda owned Arcane Studios have their
own major game on the way and one that
was also initially set for 2022 redfall
Arcane Studios Arcane Austin team was
the same team who co-developed
Dishonored developed prey and now
they're bringing forward a supernatural
FPS game pitting humans against vampires
the game takes place in red ball
Massachusetts hence the name where
vampires have taken over blacked out the
sun and the island is overrun with both
vampires and wannabe vampire cultists
you'll control four main characters each
with their own unique abilities Jacob
Boyer a sharp shooting sniper Remy De la
Rosa a combat engineer with a robot
sidekick devender crowsley a
cryptozoologist and Leila Ellison a
student who has telekinetic Powers with
arcane's fantastic track record this is
definitely one to watch for when it
releases sometime in the first half of
2023
yet again we have another game delayed
from releasing in 2022 to 2023 planet of
Alana this adorable Adventure game sees
players controlling Lana and her
mysterious animal companion mui
mechanically the game seems reminiscent
of playdead's 2D platform puzzlers which
include limbo and inside and that's not
a bad thing where play Dead's games are
tonally dark wishfully games planet of
Lana seems to be the opposite with his
trailer evoking a hopeful feeling and a
lush and beautiful off-worth planet with
what seems to be peaceful robotic
entities
next we come to my most anticipated game
of 2023 Hollow Knight silk song After
the initial announcement trailer in 2019
and a playable demo at E3 2019 fans have
been eagerly awaiting an update for
years and they finally got it during the
Xbox and Bethesda game showcased as
summer game Fest 2022 Hollow Knight is
in my humble opinion one of the greatest
metroidvania games of all time and
stands up there with the likes of Super
Metroid and Castlevania Symphony of the
Night if not dare I say topping them
silk song originally intended as an
expansion to hollow Knight grew so big
that it's become its own full-fledged
game this time around players control
Hornets a major character in a hollow
Knight who the Knight clashed with
multiple times the game will play both
similar to hollow Knight but also have
its own unique feel due to horna's
differing moveset and heal mechanic
during the build I had a chance to play
at E3 2019 according healed instantly
rather than the knight's slow charging
heel and would heal three health once
however unlike the night she couldn't
hold multiple heal charges Hollow
Knight's silk song is set to release
sometime in 2023 and according to Xbox
sometime before June 2023 it will also
be available immediately on Game Pass
upon release if you haven't played the
original Hollow Knight do me and
yourself a favor and please play it I am
begging you
turn 10 is releasing the latest game in
their popular racing Sim series Forza
Motorsport is the eighth game in the
series but turn 10 has built the game
from the ground up and ditched the eight
as is standard for Forza games the
graphics are unbelievably stunning and
some of the best you'll see on Modern
systems new features include Dynamic
time of day for every track tire and
fuel management multiple Tire compounds
and even more in-depth car building
Forza Motorsport is set to release
sometime in Spring 2023.
the stalker game's first hit the scene
in 2007 with shadow of Chernobyl and the
last game in the series was released in
2009 this FPS survival horror game
garnered fans in 2010's Metro 2033 which
shares a lot of similar themes was
created by former members of the stalker
team so if you're a fan of either you'll
be familiar with what stalker 2 is about
an alternate reality where a second
Chernobyl disaster took place creating
both mutants and strange anomalies when
it comes to surviving in this world
would you rather face an enemy bullet
from one of the many factions of the
game or one of the horrifying anomalies
and or mutants caused by the radiation
notably stalker 2 Studio GSC game world
was located in Kiev the capital of
Ukraine following Russia's Invasion many
were relocated to Prague so
understandably this game was delayed and
currently is set to release sometime in
2023
Ark survival evolves set the MMO world
of Blaze when it hit the scene in Early
Access in 2015. the game includes
survival and crafting elements to create
a world which players inhabit with
dinosaurs that can be genuinely fearsome
that said players could tame many and
even ride pterodactyls they're also able
to utilize prehistoric technology and
sci-fi Tech R2 so far has focused on
showcasing the prehistoric elements and
the latest trailer even includes Fast
and Furious star Vin Diesel although in
this context I like to think of him from
The Chronicles of Riddick escape from
butcher Bay a genuinely good game that
he was actually involved in the
development process of anyways that
aside R2 is certain to reinvigorate and
bring new people into the arc franchise
plus introduce all kinds of new elements
to the much beloved game especially
family I had to do it I'm sorry R2 is
set to release sometime in 2023
[Music]
so here's a game we know next to nothing
about but I am still incredibly excited
for nonetheless in 2020 it was revealed
that Fable is coming back Fable for
those of you who are unaware is a
fantasy action RPG series that had its
first game release in 2004. the game was
Notorious for attempting to be cutting
edge in the number of player choices it
would allow and ways players could
interact with it it was also Infamous
for the number of features Peter malinu
promised would be in the game but
weren't that said it was still a
massively successful series and even
without those promises was both charming
and a whole lot of fun to play the last
Mainline Fable game Fable 3 was released
in 2010 so it's about time that Fable
sees a return that said while there was
a teaser in 2020 for fable nothing else
has been shown as of yet so this may not
be a 2023 release but current signs
point to it being on its way sometime in
the future
hellblade that senuous sacrifice is a
fantastic psychological action game
created by Ninja Theory while it was fun
to play was brutally gorgeous and had a
fantastic art Direction the game was
even deeper than that the game follows
senua who suffers from extreme mental
illness and Trauma and the gameplay
itself utilizes these elements for senua
to solve puzzles and progress Ninja
Theory consulted with World leading
neuroscientists to try and capture the
experience of psychosis experiencing
hallucinations and delusions and
learning to live with them so senuous
Saga help lay 2 is the much anticipated
sequel in the gameplay reveal we see
even more disturbing hallucinations and
once again the question of what's real
and what's in her mind helplay 2 has no
set release date as of yet but we can
certainly hope that it's sooner than
later
was there anything we missed that you're
looking forward to in 2023 and Beyond
let us know in the comments below and
I'll see you next time